so thank you so much for joining us for
gaps in health equity insights from
history lessons from cobit 19 and ideas
for the future
this is the 10th in a series the yell
development dialogues which are virtual
panel discussions hosted by yale's
economic growth center jackson institute
for global affairs and history
department i'm catherine chaney i'm a
reporter at devex focused on technology
and innovation and global development
and i really enjoy moderating these
conversations we bring together
perspectives from history economics and
policy to discuss ways to address
challenges facing low and middle income
countries and today we're joined by
experts who are leading voices in
understanding health and healthcare
challenges globally so i have a number
of questions i'd like to ask them but
for those of you who are joining us live
here on the zoom webinar we really
encourage you to submit your questions
via the q a function and please don't
wait till the very end so that i can
have a sense of what you want to hear
and make the conversation as useful for
you as possible
transitioning to the topic that we're
tackling today we all know that unequal
access to the copit19 vaccine has
magnified what are really long-standing
gaps in health equity
and i found this definition of health
equity from the robert wood johnson
foundation to be really useful in
preparing for this conversation so i'll
share it with you health equity means
that everyone has a fair and just
opportunity to be as healthy as possible
this requires removing obstacles to
health such as poverty discrimination
and their consequences including
powerlessness and lack of access to good
jobs with fair pay quality education and
housing safe environments and health
care
so structural power inequities which the
cova 19 pandemic again has really
highlighted
results in different health outcomes
based on factors that are outside of
people's control like where they are
born
in this webinar we'll explore whether
this crisis will in fact change the
conversation on health equity and propel
the kinds of partnerships needed to
achieve it we'll ask what lessons we can
draw from the kobit 19 pandemic and from
the past in order to design a more
equitable future
i want to quickly introduce our
panelists who can share more with us
today i'm joined by ann emmanuel vern
who's professor of critical development
studies and of social and behavioral
health sciences at the dalai lana school
of public health at university of
toronto
pascaline dupac is the professor of
economics at stanford university and
faculty director of the stanford king
center on global development which also
has fantastic events they put on i
highly recommend them
dr mespan teclu tesema is head of the
health unit at the international rescue
committee and irc's senior leader in
health
and sunil amrith is the renu and anand
dawan professor of history at yale and
one of three co-organizers of the yell
development dialogue series together
with rohini pandey and rory stewart
thanks so much to all of you for joining
us
i want to begin with you sunil i mean
you've really championed this topic as
one that we should take on as part of
the yell development dialogue series
bringing these different perspectives
together and i'd love for you to expand
a bit on why this topic and why now
thank you catherine and thank you all
for joining us um
last year when we started the yale
development dialogues um we were really
in the very midst of the pandemic as we
still are in many ways and and we had a
couple of very successful conversations
on oncobit on covet and inequality
covered in development and i think one
of the messages that was loud and clear
to me from those conversations was this
is only the beginning of the
conversation that if anything covert has
highlighted just how deep-rooted
inequities and health are around the
world
as a historian i've been very interested
in
the history of
moves towards health equity both the
sort of regional and a global scale and
i think what we've seen is that
there are periods
when
there have been substantive moves
towards a greater health equity um
you see this after the second world war
where despite
mass killing there was also
technological innovation and a process
of decolonization to the point where um
with the foundation of the who with the
disease eradication campaigns though
they were flawed they were in some sense
profoundly democratizing that this was
to go back to the definition you gave us
catherine about removing some of the
obstacles to the majority of the world's
population having better conditions of
health see very different movement in
the 1970s which is really coming from
the global south and this is the
movement that leads to that very famous
slogan health for all by the year 2000.
in the 2000s i think we see a different
type of movement a kind of philanthropic
movement around the formation of gavi
and the global fund
each of these movements has its moment
and of course we could talk about the
weaknesses within each of them which
explains why perhaps they didn't have
the impact that they intended to i think
there are three questions that come out
of looking at those histories though
one is the question of accountability i
think we always
come back to this question of who's
responsible for health equity um who has
in a sense the right to make these
decisions about what
will remove the obstacles to the
majority of the world um having better
access to conditions of health
the second is this constant push and
pull between a bottom-up and a top-down
approach you know one of the criticisms
of the disease eradication campaigns of
the 50s but also of some of the more
recent philanthropic um
efforts is that they've been very
top-down not really
consultative not really responsive to
what people need in different parts of
the global south um and then the third
question is you know how does one build
political support um to make health
equity a priority not just at the level
of global institutions but you know
in each individual country where um this
is a challenge and that includes you
know right here in the united states um
so i'm very keen to hear from from our
panelists who have such a diverse range
of expertise um
their perspectives on all of these
questions
thank you sunil really helpful framing
here and um i appreciate your point
that if we need to look to history and
evaluate what worked and what didn't in
each of these movements why didn't they
have their intended impact you know we
once talked about health for all by the
year 2000 here we are in 2021 and the
sustainable development goals are one of
these frameworks looking at really
health for all by 2030. um will we get
there what will it take and what can we
learn from history so really helpful
framing um building on what we can learn
from history i'd love to bring anna
manuel into this so your work focuses on
the history and politics of
international and global health mostly
in latin america and i i wonder if you
can expand on
lessons from history when it comes to
advancing health equity
sure
um let me begin by
saying that i don't quite agree with the
notion of lessons from history i
think that perspectives uh shedding
light
contextualizing understanding
are better ways because
the context always shifts right so you
can't have
importable or exportable lessons whether
over time or over space just as some of
the very prescriptive top-down health
campaigns that sunil was mentioning are
very fraught when
peru is seen as the same as thailand is
seen as the same as botswana et cetera
so i just wanted to put that on the
table uh
to get us going i appreciate that and um
you know in terms of uh the latin
american region historically
you know i i think we also need to
consider
uh moments of
advance progress but also enormous
setbacks at not necessarily
the same
or expected moments in time in terms of
international
events so there's also
you know very peculiar or specific uh
situations in in different regions and
you know one
issue has to do with uh the rise of
social security systems actually fairly
early on
in many latin american countries that
were industrializing chile as one of the
prime examples and so there was a you
know an early social security system in
1924 set up but it was exclusive to
urban industrial workers not even their
families were included and so you had
this step forward but then the exclusion
of indigenous people of rural peoples
etc etc and then you have another uh
wave in the well expectation of wave in
the late 1930s when the popular front is
elected and
salvador allende becomes
chile's minister of health and yet the
expectation of setting up a universal
health care system fails because it gets
embroiled in some of the anti-communist
ideology and pressures in the 1940s
so you really have these waves then in
the 1950s the leftists are out of
government and they do manage to put a
a universal healthcare system in place
with certain flaws and exclusions and so
on and so we need to think about this
heterogeneity as well as kind of
narrative flipping which i'm always
concerned with this idea that you know
countries of the global south are
following or learning in the bismarckian
model or the british national health
service model in fact chileans would
argue the opposite that they the brits
just got faster to the
legislative sausage making than than the
chileans did
um but also the importance of not having
uh nostalgia for the past so no society
has ever reached uh
perfect health equity it's always a
process
uh right and so even countries that have
made enormous strides
such as cuba
have been slower in some realms than
others i mean they've worked very hard
to bring in rural folks and prioritizing
rural folks but
rather later at bringing
lgbtq
ia folks
into healthcare having their health
needs covered so i think there there's a
kind of a
a wide heterogeneity there that we need
to be mindful of when looking at history
and and thinking through those
perspectives
yes i really appreciate the nuance you
brought to this um
both that no country has reached perfect
health equity it's always a process and
that um
you know you can't have these importable
exportable lessons
context matters i think that's really
valuable thank you i want to bring
pascaline into this so your research has
focused on questions related to health
equity there are many examples of this
one being for example why there hasn't
been more investment in fighting
neglected diseases and i wonder if you
can expand
on some of your research and some of
your findings most relevant to this
topic of health equity
so my own research is not so much about
why some diseases are neglected i think
that's we know exactly why they are
neglected it's just a matter of like
economics uh unfortunately which is that
you know a lot of diseases that are
specific to really poor countries um
peop the the pharmaceutical companies
who have the incentives to do r d know
well no there's no incentives there
because the very people who need this
medicine all these vaccines cannot um
afford to pay for them uh they can't
afford to pay very much for them and
their governments cannot afford to pay
very much for them so that's just like
you know uh unfortunately where the
economics versus uh you know health
comes into play so what my own work has
been um thinking well you know given
that there is no vaccine for malaria
given that you know there is um uh
not enough investments in these negative
diseases what do we uh what can be done
in the meantime and there are some kind
of like um
how do you say coping uh strategies
there are you know ultimate badness that
you can
sleep under uh in order to um
to protect yourself and your children
and so trying to understand what are the
barriers to every household in the maya
and the epidemic area having access to
that is what i've been working on but
you know over the years what i've
realized is that there are so many of
these issues that four households in
four countries have to deal with this
you know there is a bad net uh for
maraya there is you know making sure
that your water is not contaminated
there is making sure that you have you
know enough iodine because your salt is
not advertised and uh
and also stuff like that and so that the
honest is really on the people to take
so many actions to you know cope with
the fact that their environment is not
safe and it's just it's just to me it's
not sustainable so going back to the
definition you just gave us catherine
now one of the key factors is safe
environment and to me the biggest source
of health inequity in the world is
really between you know
higher income and low-income countries
and it comes a lot from this difference
in the safety and the environment the
fact that there are some tropical
diseases or some you know issues with
the um environment of uh you know that
that uh households cannot you know
subject to in a way and unless we try to
tackle those big environmental factors
uh we are not going to get uh equity in
any way if we think of it from the point
of view of across countries not just
ways in countries and so in as much as
i'm sympathetic to you know sunils
complain about top-down apertures not
being you know well-tailored i do think
that for these huge environmental
concerns we actually need top down
because it's really about coming up with
the technologies coming up with the
vaccines
getting international resources together
to get these vaccines out um and it's
not something
at the individual level you know i i
don't have much of that you know
household country i don't have any
leverage to make that happen
um and so why the disease education
campaign after world war ii
did not go as far uh as one would have
wished um i'm gonna leave you know the
historian in the room to speak to that
uh but i do think it's important to try
to to go back uh to this um and to to
really not forget about the
about about this eternity in the
environment that people face and
within my own discipline economics i
think over the last you know 10 15 20
years there's been kind of pushback
against this sentiment that geography
matters um it's all about you know
institutions and i like just to bring
geography back onto the table because i
i just think it's a very important
factor
really really helpful um and i i want to
get back into our conversation as we all
jump in um about this debate over
geography institutions um you know i
what are the structures um that lead to
this inequity we need to sort that out
before we figure out how to tackle it um
i also really appreciated you talking
about
really what this is like at a household
level you know covering global health
and international development i write a
lot about groups working on x y or z
topic related to health equity but from
the perspective of someone in a
household it's a lot to take on and it
has to do with the safety of their
environment as you said so thank you for
that um so mesfin i'd love for you to
expand now um
kind of even further on the human
experience of health inequities because
i know
you deal with this day in and day out
health equity is very much at the center
of your work the populations that you
serve at irc often lack access to health
services so i wonder if you can expand
on the barriers to access that come up
in your work and what that looks like on
an individual level
yeah thanks um
yeah absolutely i think that is um you
know one of the challenge of our time in
terms of equitable access to health
when i think of this you know i always
go back to the 28 2008 you know report
by the virtual commission on
social determinant of health which
probably be one of the most articulate
document you know what are the condition
that actually creates health inequity
and i think a failure to address that is
what is leading us different health
outcome
and that's for true for refugees that is
true for people in low-income countries
or through for people in high-income
countries uh
so
uh when it comes to you know uh refugees
and you know population affected by
conflict these are the people
who are the most vulnerable
either directly impacted by disaster uh
or running for their life because of
conflict
and even that is growing because of you
know climate change
and i think that is a growing uh issue
that we see
and um uh
you know it's worth looking at numbers
number tells a story you know in
2021 to nearly 235 million globally it's
humanitarian aid that is 1 in 33 people
of the global population
so that is like you know before the
pandemic that was like 132 million which
was like a jump by 100 million um
so this pandemic actually has hit hard
even those four players you have the
little to the means to cop and as well
as you know
survive the impact of
uh
you know pandemic or disease so the
barrier to access to health is certainly
it has multiple factors and um uh you
know one is resource
you know despite the growing number of
refugees and internally stressed people
85 of them live in low and low middle
income countries who have also limited
the resource to provide health care for
their own population so um that creates
a huge strain when you talk about
refugees what comes on the media and the
headline is probably you know refugee in
the us or uh perhaps there is a few
migration the in in in europe who have
the means actually to handle it uh but
you know not to forget that 85 percent
of them are hosted by countries like so
so
like uganda
um
you know ethiopia or uh you know
pakistan so um you know understanding
the need is
is the starting point
uh of course you know the humanitarian
system has been generous in terms of
providing a resource but you know it has
not been able to match with a growing
need you know today you know for uh
population we need direct humanitarian
assistance which is uh uh under the un
uh an oicha mandate
only 36 36 percent of the need are met
as of september you know last month and
which means that you know people are
basically living in a situation where
there is no much resource actually to
provide the care that they need
so um
and the other thing is you know these
places are characterized by conflict in
a way that health facilities are damaged
or destroyed and health care workers are
killed you know the safeguarding for
health coalition
uh who regularly monitor report in 2020
um you know that attack on health care
system has grown so in a way that uh
when all these situations are
compounding
and even the little resources available
are actually cannot be accessed by the
population
and uh that is a you know the kind of
situation people are experiencing so
perhaps maybe this reporting might under
count even and the real number of
attacked health care workers even much
larger than what's already reported
and of course um you know the other
issue is that refugees by nature they
are people who are running for their
life they are marginalized and there is
no political incentive for countries
actually to provide protection
unless they are you know uh uh ex they
have expressed policy to support or host
refugees and also it's politically
divisible you know uh point you remember
in uh the peak of european refugee
crisis from syria
the german uh chancellor you know played
to receive 1 million syrian refugees and
we remember how she received a backlash
you know for that commitment so
really including refugees doesn't gain
your electoral vote and as a result you
know these are people who are being
marginalized don't not necessarily
included in the national uh response
plan and when it comes to kobe today
many national plans don't include
refugees in the covered vaccination
rollout that's why kova has created what
is called this the humanitarian buffers
stock which is to meet those population
who may not be otherwise included by the
national government and i think you know
i can't go on to you know into the
policies uh
and uh you know the number of people who
ratified even the un convention uh for
refugee as well as additional protocol
which provide the legal mandate for
countries to provide protection and as
well as the kind of assistance refugees
can expect from government but not every
country has a you know signatory to
those convention as a result um you know
the population are left at the mercy of
humanitarian assistance and kindness not
necessarily the people who have the
right to claim
great points thank you so much i i want
to pick up on one thing you said which
you mentioned climate change and in
terms of the urgency for action i'm glad
you mentioned that because that's going
to only worsen
these health equity challenges
and really you know increases that
urgency for action um i want to pick up
on a theme that came up throughout some
of your remarks um and that's whether
you know we we've kind of talked about
what are these challenges when it comes
to health equity in terms of the path
forward and as i said at the outset the
kinds of partnerships needed to tackle
these challenges um one thing that that
came up a couple of times sumial
mentioned it pascaline mentioned it is
this idea of whether top-down works um
whether top-down is needed um and there
seemed to be maybe some disagreement on
that which i think is actually
interesting in terms of having a
discussion here um and mesfan you just
mentioned policy policy being critical
and a challenge you're facing um when it
comes to addressing health equity so so
let's talk about that for a moment and a
reminder to our audience keep those
questions coming in on q a because i
certainly have a lot of questions but i
want to hear yours um
but would love to just get your thoughts
any reactions you have on
how top down hazard hasn't worked in
your work on from whether a historical
perspective an economics perspective a
policy and practice perspective i think
that'd be an interesting
topic to just hear your thoughts on so
sunil or mesmen i saw you on view please
jump in
uh sure just in a couple of points from
me um
i mean it depends on the issue we are
dealing of course there are room for
both top down as well as bottom up and i
think you know we need to be very clear
when we have a global pandemic like
kovic
we do need you know whole of society
response and that includes you know
communities um you know uh national
government as well as the global system
need to function including the un system
as well as the pharmaceutical and all of
the you know international system but um
you know
unfortunately some of the systems are
not efficient to respond to pandemic you
know if you look at access to technology
uh which is a critical for uh
you know for vaccine and we have a
system that basically protect access to
technology through this the world trade
organization intellectual property
related agreement and it's not flexible
and it also gives undue influence for
people with um you know high-income
countries not to make the system work
for uh equity equitable access to
technology so i we should recognize
those inefficiencies in the system that
may not be deploying the kind of
resistance we need to respond but at the
same time if you look at uh access to
vaccine and demand you know that's where
um you know
addressing misinformation engaging
communities from the outset and creating
really an enabling environment where
even the limited
available resource can be
taken up so i would
think that you know we need to pick our
tools you know in the right way and i'm
not in favor of you know one way works
better than the other but it depends on
the the situation that we are dealing
with thanks yeah that makes a lot of
sense go ahead in my in for my part i
think it was probably unhelpful on my
part of the beginning to sort of frame
it as top down versus bottom up though
that is often how this is kind of um
framed as a problem i i think you know
clearly there are moments when um
depending on the scale of the problem
and i think this does come down to scale
there are different kinds of challenges
to health equity that operate on very
very different scales and you know we
probably need to sort of deal with the
more a global pandemic on the one hand
and you know perhaps much more localized
kinds of challenges on the other um i i
think one of the questions historically
speaking is um you know it's undoubted
that top-down um campaigns or
interventions have very often had rapid
and um effective results
what we often find is that those aren't
sustained and i think that's where the
kind of multi-layered or multi-level
sort of intervention that dr jessema is
talking about i think becomes very
important you know after the initial
impact of talk about the disease
eradication campaigns of the 1950s um
initially they were tremendously
successful particularly against malaria
but then partly because um of sort of
vertical structure of those campaigns
there was very often sort of diminishing
returns to that and then i think
environmental challenges also come into
this um
i wanted to sort of um
jump in and ask uh pascaline very
interesting what you were saying about
how
you know geography matters and you're
you're keen to sort of bring that back
in and i wonder if there are insights
from your work about how
countries in the global south which face
similar environmental conditions um then
have very different trajectories when it
comes to health outcomes i mean do you
have you found that there are sort of
particular
so that it's not just the environment if
the environmental conditions or the
propensity to certain kinds of tropical
diseases are shared um do you
nevertheless see
significant divergence between different
countries as a result of the kinds of
policy
interventions that are made and which
ones are sort of effective there
um
i know animator wanted to jump in
earlier so at some point we should make
sure that to give it a mic but um you
know very quickly uh i mean the the
evidence that um i mean comparing things
across countries is um something that
you know as economists we try to to not
do too much because we know that there
are so many things that can come into
play but uh so what i can tell you for
sure that within a country there is a
clear correlation in terms of health
outcomes and and the environment um that
that people face uh depending on you
know variation in suitability to to
various diseases
but of course when you move out of you
know infectious diseases and move out of
you know things that are very much
driven by um
but by the environment there is a
therapeutic and there is a virginity in
the strength of the health system the
detergent in um you know access to to to
health insurance in uh you know
governance and and that matters a lot
for whether the health workers are going
to be
you know well trained and well motivated
and present so there's definitely a lot
of things that can be done
um in that you know uh on you know on
the side like uh
my and and i think a lot of the research
has been focused on that because it's
kind of like easier uh to think about
these
approaches and to work on these
approaches with you know individual
governments in your organizations uh
because as the manual said before um
it's very you know context-specific so
it's very hard to be prescriptive and
say this is how you're going to improve
you know or strengthen your health
system it really depends on the context
and so doing this uh you know localized
uh uh work to make progress i think it's
been what you know at least in my field
people
so this is possible so let's do that
uh i just want to say you know there's a
ceiling to where we can go with that
um and on the larger environmental stuff
we need uh we need a global effort
just building on that for a second i
mentioned earlier um the robert wood
johnson foundation one
interesting role i've seen philanthropy
play um is not just directly funding
work to address health equity but trying
to highlight what are some of those
exemplars kind of building on sunil's
question like um despite some similar
challenges that different geographies
might face
there have been better outcomes in this
place and why is that and and funding um
research on why and sharing that um
research to inform work in other
contexts but as any as an emanuel said
earlier um contacts are quite different
and context matters so i do want to
bring you in though because i know you
had a comment to make earlier yeah yeah
it's not just that context matters it's
politics and power that matter and i
think those elements have been under
emphasized in the conversation thus far
even if we're looking at the difference
between health care equity and health
equity we see this playing out in very
very patent ways
and so rather than
important as it is looking at the the
the symptoms or the end game the
horrific situation of
refugees or so-called neglected diseases
and what we should be doing is asking
who is doing the neglecting why and how
after all trypanosomiasis was not
neglected in the late 19th and early
20th century by german and british and
other colonial powers rather it was a
huge threat to territorial expansion and
acquisition right so how and why
certain health conditions become more or
less important under particular contexts
at the global level and then where
politics both local and global play out
in sunil mentioned at the outset of
change in the 1970s but really this
change was coming starting with
decolonization in the 1950s a banjon
conference and a non-aligned movement
and the largest you know the g77 the
largest political grouping within the
united nations that was able to push for
the concept and ideally the approach of
a new international economic order so
you know how is it and why is it that
power is distributed so unequally so yes
the trip's agreement and adherence to it
a huge issue in terms of vaccine access
right but then the question is how is it
that the wto gets set up
under whose influence right and why are
the rules of the game so uneven and so
unfair in terms of you know europe has
uh plenty and north america have uh
plenty of subsidies for agriculture and
this is prevented for global south
countries who are not permitted to have
tariffs and so on so i think what we
need to do getting back to this health
and health care equity situation is
think through what the structural
determinants or
uh societal determination of health as
uh jaime brey and other latin american
social medicine scholars put it and
think through not just what the factors
are but what are the processes and the
rules of the game and the power wielding
that takes place i mean you know the
refugee situation at bottom needs to be
addressed by addressing militarism
right and the fact that five
of the five permanent members of the
security council are the largest arms
exporters
in the world it you know is a
massive problem that needs priority now
you could say well you've got a
situation on the ground
you know how can you deal quickly with
structural issues but we've been saying
this for decades and decades right so
if not now when right it it it is time
and you know the fact that so many
have suffered in such a great extent and
of course far greater uh extent from
from covet 19 in countries with
huge asymmetries economic social
political asymmetries
is a wake-up call but certainly nothing
new and so
you know i think it behooves us all who
work in the larger global development
field really to be constantly pushing at
all ends
and certainly on these structural
factors lest they be
placed in the background as they
typically are i totally agree so let's
let's bring those structural factors to
the foreground any any reactions to what
anna manuel just said and how you know
we've had these conversations before but
is is the conversation any different
this time in terms of the power and
politics at play when it comes to health
and equity health care inequity
you might want to jump in go ahead
pascaline
so
so i think deep down i i fully agree
with with any mandarin but at the same
time it it makes me
so
kind of despondent and pessimistic when
i think about the fact that okay we're
not gonna make any progress if we don't
if we don't you know change all of this
structural problem i feel like
it's kind of even one you know
extra uh layer of you know
um you know already i was saying it's
hard to think about getting agreement to
fix the environment
um
if on top of that we have to bring in
the you know
militarism i mean i just feel like
people ask
it's not happening and let's just give
up so i i i i'm
i want to find you know um room um
for progress in the very short run
uh
but then there's always this tension
like how do we make progress in the
short run without you know
forgetting um to also deal with these
deep issues in in that are like so
important so i i hear you and i just
feel like how do you you know
do you see do you see
any
hope for for change um on the on those
fronts
yeah sure um give me a couple of
thoughts i mean you know when you look
at the problem i think an emanuel has
painted the picture you may feel like
that you know you know we are paralyzed
you know what can you do
um i do believe you know there are you
know effort really to address this you
know when it comes to developmental
inequity i mean we have seen for example
how the mdg helps to address child
mortality and maternal mortality and we
move to the scd with a mantra of you
know leaving no one behind
but you know that
was tested during the pandemic whether
after what we mean leaving nova behind
when you are rolling out the vaccine
actually we have left everybody behind
so in a way i think um
we have to translate this high level of
rhetoric into actionable
uh you know plan and implementation and
there are a couple of efforts you know
to bring the humanitarian development
peace building initiative through what's
called in humanitarian development peace
and access you know recognizing that you
know these are not you know dichotomy
that exists in parallel it's actually
the same countries that are going
through different level of fragility and
also countries affected by conflict and
also the same countries where we think
you know uh
we should be doing development aid so in
a way how do you bring the actor
together in a way that we can address
the root causes not only just uh you
know sending humanitarian aid when
people are starting to move so
and again you know when it comes to
health the pandemic has taught us that
we need to invest in public health
infrastructure and public health
infrastructure is not something that is
you know
appealing to private sector and this is
where government need to invest uh on
this is surveillance you know probably
that's not what the private sector would
be interested to invest so in a way i
think you know a situation where you
know government has a role to play i
think that role has to be enforced with
through accountability and also we need
to measure and show where there is
progress so that people can see what's
working what's not working
and uh you know translating this broad
you know
mantra of like universal higher health
coverage or you know leaving no one
behind what does it mean in practical
sense when you are you know doing either
vaccination or when you are dealing with
you know
a disease or any of the uh health issues
that we are dealing so
uh i'm you know i do believe that there
is a way but i think what is missing in
many ways is you know lack of political
will and of course you know
unless you have a democratic system
where electorate can hold you know um
leaders accountable uh unfortunately you
know that's uh rhetoric which may not be
necessarily translated but i think we
need to you know measure and show where
this is happening and probably you know
uh learn from the countries who are
doing better
absolutely go ahead
i was just going to say i you know
the idea is not to feel despondent in
fact it's an enormous privilege to be
able to feel despondent as opposed to
needing to take action day-to-day
you know i think what's crucial is
understanding
how the global
order the global political economy
operates right and then think through
uh as muslin was suggesting what are
some of the levers right and perhaps
some of the best levers are you know why
not a campaign to ultimately put
humanitarian organizations out of
business all due respect so that we
don't need them
in a few years right so that we have a a
a system where it's it's safe uh to live
in sudan and there's a redistribution
of income and resources so that everyone
has a decent housing and decent
education and piped water and
paved roads and so
and and and full employment and good
employment right so that we don't have
these hugely inequitable uh effects and
impacts on the most oppressed groups of
people so you know i i do think we
need to use our own
positions of privilege to to speak out
and to point to these connections and to
go beyond you know you mentioned
partnerships i really worry about
public-private partnerships because
the private sector and certainly the
corporate sector and the business of
maximizing profits not in the business
of improving social conditions so i i
think one needs to be quite cautious and
in that regard in the in regard of
partnerships which unfortunately the
sdgs are emphasizing and also
to
seek to support true uh democratic
movements and efforts and there's been
so much intervention certainly in the
cold war but in other time periods when
there is um you know what people's
uprising for
a new form of accountable government
and
the us or other forces have come in and
nipped those uh efforts uh often very
violently in the bud so
you know again big issues but not ones
that we can ignore
absolutely and i think this is
resonating with the audience i'm going
to share a comment from the audience um
and maybe we can kind of gear it into
the form of a question but this attendee
says thank you and emanuel for
addressing the power dynamics that
influence health i am very interested in
the intersection of health equity and
economics equity cannot be achieved
until root causes colonialism racism
unfair trade practices etc are addressed
so that's just a comment to give you a
sense of where at least one member of
our audience um is standing and seeing
these issues um i have some specific
questions i want to dive into and i want
to bring in more from the audience but i
want to give space for any panelists to
jump in with reactions to neil yeah if i
might just pick up to develop the
conversation um and including that
interesting comment from our um audience
member um i want to pick up on something
um said which was um
the question of political will
and particularly the question of um you
know what political will means in
different kinds of political system one
of the things that's always puzzled i
think many of us who work on health in
south asia
is
how
rarely
health or health equity
have been major political issues even in
india even in the context of um
regular democratic competition um
things might be changing in india but
let's bracket that for a minute um
some parts of india this is also
profoundly context-specific there are
some parts of india where um you know
governments perhaps do fall
over questions of health but by and
large that has not been the case they've
never been the case in india since
independence i'm not sure i have a
reason i'm not sure i have an answer to
why i've been thinking about this for 20
years and i'm not really sure what it is
whereby in certain societies and i think
ann emanuel your latin american examples
are probably better ones there um there
has been mass mobilization for
health um
coming from a kind of upsurge of you
know democratic demand and there are
places where that hasn't happened and i
just wanted to put that on the table
because i don't i don't have answers to
it but it is something that has often
puzzled me and when mesut mentioned
political will i think that's true you
know not just at the level of of
the permanent members of security
council on global governments but also
in a sense in a sense that continues all
the way down um you know even to the
level of local government where is it
and when is it that
health equity to use just the topic of
our discussion today
um
becomes something people fight for
and emmanuel did you have a reaction to
that well i was i was just gonna say i
think in south asia they're the classic
examples of of kerala the state of
kerala in southern india and and then
sri lanka and so in the case of sri
lanka you know a free
universal health free the point of
service universal health care system uh
that developed quite quickly in the
post-colonial period and was fought for
and struggled for and
you know exists in a certain to a
certain extent to this day i mean it's
being
ratcheted down through another force
that we haven't discussed which is the
neoliberal phase of global capitalism
but um you know in in the case of carol
it's so interesting that you know there
at times have been communist governments
at times not but the public support for
universal public
health care and education and you know
housing supports and so on is so strong
that even when the communists are
elected out of office and another party
is in power
those issues remain on the table so
you know political will doesn't simply
come from politicians but it comes from
those who are holding as as was said by
muslim holding politicians accountable
and also seeing what's possible right
once that's tasted uh then the demands
also rise to a great extent i mean i
think we're seeing that in brazil with
the uprising against bolsonaro when in
you know prior decades there's this
creation of a fantastic
a single
health care system and enormous social
investments and you know family wages
and so on that would enable uh 40
million people to be uh lifted out of
poverty and so on and so people are
are you know reacting against that and
people in the streets so i i i do think
it happens and including in south asia
notwithstanding you know repressive
governments at times and including now
in in india
well i think the point i think i think
you're absolutely right andy manuel the
point is more that carol and sri lanka
are such outliers in south asia the
question is you know why is it happening
there tamil nadu to some extent but but
nevertheless i mean i think that that's
why they're so interesting i think it's
it and there has been so much sort of
study what it is about those two
particular contexts um and i think you
know there are there are many other
examples around the world which which i
take you know
optimism from to some extent that there
have been repeated sort of mobilizations
to hold um the powers that be
accountable in relation to health
i want to bring in a question um and
this is something i'm personally very
interested in so hopefully our audience
is as well but when we talk about levers
for short-term progress even as we are
addressing these larger structural
issues that need addressing
i cover
innovation and technology quite a bit
and at least perhaps this is an
overhyped space but digital is often
brought up as something that could
advance health equity
it's also possibly something that can
worsen um health inequities because not
everyone for example has access to
broadband or smartphones um but i did
just want to bring up
the role of digital i'm curious if
panelists have reactions to that i know
anna manuel for example you did some
work on whether digital technology can
address health inequities both within
across within and across countries and
you concluded that it can be a useful
tool but only under certain conditions
so i wonder if you can just quickly
expand
on what are those conditions and then
i'd love to hear if other panelists have
reactions on how that's come up in your
work
um sure
well
you i think you can't uh consider
technology divorced from
social and political conditions so it's
not just a dog sex machina that drops
down i mean even if you had
uh well we have a supposed malaria
vaccine now although it's really an
immune booster but anyway leave that
aside
um you know even if you had that right
this this quick fix
what would happen then to all of the
efforts to improve housing stock right
so that would end up generating further
uh inequities and then of course
who who would be reached who wouldn't be
reached and so on so i i also think it's
crucial especially with current day
technology to think through every step
of the commodity change so we are using
digital devices
uh constantly without taking into
account
uh the
thousands of
child artisanal miners in the democratic
republic of congo who were abused
mistreated exposed to cobalt in the
mining process etc etc not to mention
every other step in the commodity chain
so we tend to kind of put technology in
this very decontextualized box and you
know yes we certainly our interactions
are are all shaped by technology but
technology is also shaped by uh the very
power structures that we've been talking
about today i mean who owns
technological companies what's the role
of metal mining you know i come from a
country canada
that has a heinous record a human rights
uh an ill health record in terms of its
uh mining um involvement in latin
america it's extractive industries in
latin america so i i think it's really
morally and really analytically bereft
to not consider the role of techno or to
talk about digital technology and equity
without considering all of these
implications
so it's you know if you it could be a
useful tool but when it's embedded in
policies that redistribute power and
resources and do not concentrate harms
which technology absolutely does
good points on technology things i
should definitely keep in mind in my
reporting i love your point on not
putting it in a decontextualized box so
i don't mean to do that but any other
reactions to the role it might play
while considering that complexity go
ahead nesmin
yeah i know i think um
you know
technology has a huge promise in terms
of addressing health and equity
especially in you know in sub-saharan
africa for example the place i know well
that how much actually mobile technology
has transformed people people people's
life whether it's mobile payment for
example access to cash for people who
are not traditionally connected to the
mainstream banking system um so
uh you know access to information of
course you know it has to be regulated
it has to be in a language that's
understandable by the local uh
uh community and um uh you know it has
to be there should be some level of
digital literacy as well that go with it
you know it can be harmful as it is
useful it is and we have seen how
you know misinformation can spread very
fast through social media and all of
this
um but at the same time the same
platform can be
a cause for good uh
cause so i mean it has you know
a a a a lot of potential and in
humanitarian settings um this is one of
the area where access to information is
actually as vital as life-saving as it
is like access to food
you know i recall during the syria
crisis earlier days even for people
where to seek asylum and what is their
knowing their legal rights and um
what is the safest place you know to be
and for children so all these kind of
emotions are life-saving for people
when they're uh when they are on the
move
so
um i do think you know technology has
you know enormous potential but um you
know as many i i immanuel said it has to
be regulated in a way that is uh
you know used and it can also cause harm
if it is not you know proper to you to
utilize so you know in the place where i
work i think it has been it's taking off
you know addressing many of the issues
that is related to health inequity
other thoughts on technology otherwise i
certainly have other questions go ahead
and pass elaine
i just wanted to add one one area where
it can be
useful
which is um disease surveillance uh you
know uh early warning system identifying
when there is um an epidemic starting
let's think of like ebola
or you know even in the context of
coffee has been extremely useful um to
be able to kind of have a sense of like
where there is a
uh more or less people being infected
and technology can definitely help with
that with you know with obviously all
the drawbacks that that means also like
monitoring
people um you know and there's like the
big brother you know so surveillance is
a term that can be interpreted as uh you
know
uh you know very uh
um negatively or very positively whether
or not you're thinking of traveling
people are surveilling the the
so i'm not saying that this is
necessarily always um a great tool but
you know in some some context it feels
like
uh i think giving especially in context
where the
the health system may not be strong
enough yet for people to feel
uh that they can trust that you know
during an ebola crisis if i go to the
health care uh system am i going to get
it whatever i'm gonna you know uh being
able to like communicate information uh
about their own symptoms you know
through the phone for example would be a
great way to to help um deal with crisis
so that's one one extra area where i
think it could be useful but i also want
to say i don't think it's a penance yeah
i got a phone call where you know
silicon valley like every student comes
and says hey i have this new app that's
going gonna like solve every problem on
the planet and i'm like no
i strongly doubt that so i tend to have
like an outside technology uh point of
view just you know as a reaction to you
know the average person around camp um i
see on campus here but so everyone said
there are a lot of areas where i think
technology is not going to get us there
um and i want to bring us back to the
point i met earlier about the fact that
they are just like some some diseases um
that uh we just don't yet have um tools
for um and
and maya is one of them when it comes to
vaccines there is now some hope that
there is a
vaccine that may be partially uh
effective
uh and you know the the question is you
know how do we make sure that this is
like that all out uh widely um
you know as quickly as possible
i i want to come back to you each just
very quickly and i hate to make you
respond in about 30 seconds or so but if
you can that would be ideal because i do
want to bring in all your perspectives
one more time on this question of this
is something pascaline mentioned as we
were getting ready for this call she
mentioned that you know over the years
she's seen several openings where
there's a possibility for action to
address health inequity but then those
moments come and go and i wonder if
you're optimistic that this moment might
be any different um and if it is to be
different if real progress is to be made
what needs to happen so just quickly
coming back to each of you
how might this moment be different if
you're at all optimistic it can be and
what needs to happen pascaline can we
start with you
so yeah so i mean i just take the media
accent as an example you know recently i
got i saw an article by the
cdg that i i got very unhappy with
because he said look let's think twice
about this vaccine it's not as cost
effective as other stuff and it was like
oh it's two hundred dollars per day
compared to like 60 for something else
i'm like two hundred dollars for per day
disability addresses like it's nothing
like in the u.s we spend like thousands
of dollars per days every time so it's
it is super cost effective and we just
have to
move beyond just saying there's not
enough money and we have to go for the
really really really really cheap stuff
we should have more money uh available
for that and i think there is an opening
there because
everybody here um you know has seen what
it means to be in an environment where
you're afraid of getting a disease from
your neighbor all the time we we know
that we are willing to make sacrifices
to just like get rid of that damn covey
okay everybody has been doing that and
now we can put ourselves in the shoes of
people who have been living in the
marijuana
pascaline you've just cut out for me can
you hear us
okay i'm going to go ahead and bring
mespanin and hopefully pascaline's
connection will improve in one moment
we've been fishing for a year and a half
vasculean i'm so sorry your signal's
cutting out for me your signal cut out
for me right there um but now i think we
see you can you just wrap up we missed
the last little bit of what you said
oh sorry let's just move on to the next
panel sorry about my best connections oh
i was leaning in and so engaged in what
you were saying but i think i i
understand um where you were going with
it and and um i think i think we
understood you enough to be able to
build on that so mesmen can we go to you
next
yeah sure
um
you know when it comes to the greatest
challenge of our time which we started
with cover 19 pandemic as well as i
added climate change
um as you know everyone is talking about
the need for
building back better
uh but there is far too little attention
in terms of the disparity in terms of
access to power and resource between
high and low income countries even the
most fragile states so i do consider you
know this as a blind spot you know to
addressing the root cause of you know
injustice whether it's vaccine or you
know humanitarian crisis um so you know
overlooking you know those contexts is a
strategic error as well and i do think
you know if you want to be
serious about building back better
probably you know for a world that we
want to see not the one we left behind
um
we need to translate this rhetoric into
concrete action
and through an inclusive governance
system and which is accountable
as well and uh you know the pandemic has
taught us that you know investment in
public health should be a public good
that government should not you know
delegate this responsibility to private
sector and we need to look at um the
whole health
health governance system including
international health regulation for uh
this is pandemic reporting and so that
really addressing those issues that are
paralyzing now
to have a better world and i think we
need to look at our governance and
accountability mechanism to have a
fairer world
thank you mess finn um and we're coming
close to the end of time but anna manuel
would love to hear your thoughts
yeah so i agree with mesfin that power
asymmetries are the
crucial issue of the day and
uh of many many years in fact um and i
think you know i wouldn't say optimistic
but hopeful in a range of actions that
have taken place in different parts of
the world the so-called striketober in
north america so attempts to unionize at
amazon in edmonton and here in canada
even though it failed in alabama you
know john deere strikes gig worker
strikes and so on all of the revelations
about
corporate capitalism
and so on extremely important and
together with those worker uprisings
there have been some notable indigenous
uprisings up and down
uh the americas for example i mean
ecuador uh in cuenca passed a resolution
a referendum
uh for clean water and kicking out a
canadian mining company that's a huge
form of resistance and i think something
to be hopeful for and and build upon
likewise uh elections in peru and
finally in bolivia overturning
you know a repressive government that
was supported by north america
so i i think there are reasons for uh
some some hope uh and that is in the
context of people's struggles right not
in terms of you know experts developing
better technologies divorced from all of
that
thank you samil how are you feeling as
we close this conversation and how do we
make sure that this moment doesn't just
come and go in terms of an opportunity
to advance health equity
i think one thing i've taken from this
conversation is
the need for
you know for joined up thinking um we
didn't talk much about climate change um
that has very much been on my mind and i
think thinking about the ways in which
environmental justice um maps onto
health equity i think
without that i don't think anything that
we do will we will succeed because in a
sense i think that you know covered
devastating though it has been is is a
relatively fleeting crisis compared with
the climate crisis and i think the ways
in which climate change just sort of
supercharges all of these existing
inequalities is something that we will
have to confront um i wouldn't say i'm
optimistic but nevertheless i think you
know there are enough people and
particularly young people all over the
world who are deeply concerned about the
climate crisis to make me think that if
if ever there's going to be an
opportunity to sort of start to connect
those dots um you know this this might
be as good as it gets for the next
little while
thank you sunil well thank you all so
much for joining us apologies we went a
bit over on time there but there was a
lot of complexity to get into again this
conversation was part of a larger series
the yell development dialogues our next
event which will focus on afghanistan
will take place on tuesday november 16th
so stay tuned for information on that
thank you again so much to our panelists
to all of you for joining and to our
co-hosts yale's economic growth center
jackson institute for global affairs and
history department see you next time
you